hello everyone and welcome to round six
of this year's fed Grand Swiss we have a
very nice game on board one Andre yeno
versus hikaro Nakamura featuring an
opening we have not seen in a very long
time maybe even we were're seeing it For
The First Time In classical chess uh it
is the hyper accelerated Dragon uh a
very sharp opening that you uh if you
don't know it's very very easy to get
lost uh and uh especially if you've done
some work on the on the normal Dragon
you might get mixed up in some of the
lines now uh the reason why someone uh
would play the hyper accelerated Dragon
instead of the uh normal Dragon I'm just
going to show you what it is E4 C5 this
San defense and now after Knight to F3
the immediate Pawn to G6 uh it's only
the fourth most popular continuation and
um uh by for I mean there are maybe like
13,000 games in the database played from
Top tier tournaments whereas from uh the
main lines you know the D6 the E6 Knight
to C6 there are like maybe 300,000 games
in the database alog together so so uh
definitely a sideline when it's uh when
a sicilian is considered and like I said
the reason why you would play it is uh
if you're just starting out and you
don't want to learn all the theory on
the Sicilian and you really like the
dragon setup uh it requires you to learn
maybe three lines instead of 300 lines
now uh this also means that it's going
to be much easier for white to play as
white also needs to learn um uh you know
not not so many lines and here usually
everyone counters it with Pawn to D4 the
pretty standard idea and the game that
really helped me uh to understand how to
play against this type of Sicilian the
hyper accelerator dragon is the one that
Anish giri played against Magnus Carlson
in the uh 2021 I believe it was um the
Magnus Carson Invitational and Anish won
brilliantly and he won in the main line
of this hyper accelerated Dragon which I
thought um was impossible and he even
played one move that the engine said it
was like disgusting the the engine said
no do not play this move but um it's
obviously incredibly strong and Magnus
could not uh find his way out of this
move so I haven't covered this game yet
for some reason I will at some point so
that's uh just what I wanted to uh
mention but here uh we don't have the
the main D4 move we have Pawn to C3 so
sort of the uh slow W the the alapin
variation against the hyper accelerated
Dragon uh we have Pawn to D5 and now
Pawn to E5 grabbing more space in the
center and now Pawn to A6 and there are
a couple of games in the database I
found five of them and all of them
played exclusively by jonger vako uh and
he drew four of them and lost one of
them but he is the only player that um
plays this setup we have ped D4 Knight
to C6 and now there is a game where
Bishop to E2 was played but here we have
Pawn to H3 and already now as of move
six we have a completely new game so
let's see what Hikaru had in mind Bishop
to G7 we have Bishop to E2 and now Pawn
to F6 immediately uh attacking white
strong setup in the center here e
captures on F6 we have Knight captures
on F6 and now both players castle and
now Bishop to E3 again very standard
stuff you see that um Hikaru has a very
strong attack here in the center so you
want to add more support C captures on
D4 C captures and now Knight to H5 just
putting more pressure there on D4 and
preparing to put the Knight on F4 which
will put pressure on the bishop somewhat
you will never be able to capture and
also Hikaru wants to start advancing
that g Pawn to G5 and maybe even to G4
so Rook to E1 uh and now just Knight to
F4 with attacking the bishop Hikaru of
course wants to keep the bishop pair he
plays Bishop to F1 and now he car played
Pawn to G5 and um it's a very
complicated position where the speno
went into a 30 minute think because
there really is a lot to consider here
of course you're not considering U
capturing on G 5 that would be silly if
you Capt on G5 then E5 and now you
really have problems the Knight is
hanging also the everything is nicely
defended here play the Knight back then
even Knight the pawn to E4 now chases
away the Knight which is defending the
D4 square and then your Bishop is really
tied out down to the defense of the D4
pawn and hear just gets too much out of
The Possession the bishop is in the game
you have the semiopen f file for The
Rook uh this would be a dream position
for a tactical player like Hikaru so
instead we have Knight to E5 this sort
of prevents E5 for the moment and um
prevents Pawn to G4 but it does require
him to sacrifice a pawn so okay there's
nothing better for Hikaru he takes the
pawn Knight captures Pawn captures and
Bishop captures on E5 and now just
Knight to C3 yeso continues development
we have Pawn to E6 now defending the D5
pawn and the bishop to C5 putting
pressure on hikaru's Rook we have Bishop
to D6 and now Bishop to D4 sort of
winning a move here uh uh as the D5
square is nicely covered now you don't
have to worry about E5 so he car
prepares it Knight to G6 and now we have
Knight to
A4 uh going after Knight to B6 it's just
going to be a very very annoying piece
and also uh you will either win material
or you're going to win the bishop pair
or something uh but Hikaru says Nope
Bishop to C7 and he stops it all
together now a most complicated way to
handle Knight A4 would be B5 I'm just
going to show it because it's a
classical game and this move
uh would really uh you know uh brighten
our days but it I I believe it would
require too much time to calculate and
both of them were already uh down to
some maybe half an hour uh so here point
the point is after Knight to B6 you can
play Pawn to E5 you sort of sacrifice
The Rook but white will not take it
white will move the bishop now you play
Pawn to D4 Queen to B3 with check King
to G7 and now you play Knight captures
on A8 uh but you don't capture material
you go for Bishop to B7 you develop uh
on this beautiful diagonal Bishop back
to D2 white gets the piece out of the uh
out of Harm's Way and now Queen to F6
even you go after the F2 pawn and once
white defends this you can even play H6
and defend the G5 Pawn point being that
even though the Knight escapes to B6 it
can't escape any further all of these
squares are covered you're going to play
Rook F7 take away the D7 Square from the
Knight and the Knight still has no
squares to go to and it's going to uh
fall eventually so a very interesting
way of playing but Hikaru decides nope
I'm not calculating that he just plays
Bishop to C7 or maybe he calculated it
out and decided that this was better uh
also possible as he car calculates very
very quickly we have Bishop to D3 now
putting pressure on the Knight also
maybe with some ideas of doubling up the
pawns but really Queen to H5 is the main
plan and here the situation on the clock
was 28 minutes for Andre and 38 minutes
some for Hikaru uh and Hikaru throws
Down The Gauntlet he plays Pawn to E5
and now either ISO will uh calculate
well or he won't or maybe he will
overreach somewhere or it will just
fizzle out into a draw uh so is Peno
goes for Bishop captures on G6 and now e
captures on D4 and the idea is that if
is Peno tries to keep the bishop into
the game let's say Bishop to D3 then
Queen to D6 and already white is now the
one who who has problems uh but is SP
says nope you can have the bishop just
Queen to H5 and now it's he car to move
does he accept the draw or does he try
something better now a very nice attempt
for him would be if possible if is Queen
to D7 you guard on H7 you put pressure
on the Knight and you just prepare to
continue developing your pieces and
bring more Firepower into the game the
problem is this would lose um uh on on
the spot and it's a although it's a
hypothetical position feel free to pause
the video and figure out how white wins
this while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
realizing that the queen uh has to
protect the seventh Rank and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course The Rook lift The Rook
comes to E6 and now there is no defense
against Bishop captures on H7 followed
by some very nasty checks with the Rook
uh now the idea is okay even if you play
Bishop to E5 uh sort of to maybe give up
the bishop for
uh for something like H Capt and G6 uh
now Knight to B6 just wins you attack
the queen and the rook and black loses
material and if you don't play this what
else is there to try uh you can play
something of course you cannot capture
The Rook if you capture The Rook you
just get checkmated if you try something
like B5 you attack the Knight then
Knight C5 attacks the queen and defends
The Rook uh although it doesn't requ
require defending but still let's say
queen G7 and now the main idea Bishop
captures an H7 just wins you capture or
you don't doesn't really matter of
course Rook to G6 check King h8 and now
Rook to H6 will win the black queen and
um very quickly the game so after this
queen to H5 move he car did not go for
this of course he played H captures on
G6 and now there is no other way to
conclude the game other than Queen
captures on G6 with check King to h8 and
now Queen to H6 the game very quickly uh
and ended with AIP repetition of moves
but just uh um I'll show you that it's
not possible if you could somehow get
this Rook to H5 or H4 or H6 okay it
would be checkmated but there's just no
way to do it even if you try something
sneaky like Knight to B6 hoping to get
D5 Square for The Rook black will even
allow it it's not a problem and after
Rook to E5 uh the problem is there's
this bishop to F5 move attacking the
queen and now you really have to capture
otherwise black is fully developed and
you're just going to lose the game so
you're going to have to trade here
captures captures and or even better
just give a check and after King to G8
now you continue checking and now we
either have a Perpetual or if black
insist you can go to the f file then
give up The Rook with check and now you
have to go back you cannot allow the
rookie one to land with check so King G8
Queen to G6 check and so on if you go to
G7 then Rook to E1 will again be dead
deadly for black uh so yeah after king
h8 queen to H6 was played and here we
had a nice repetition and on move 27
Andre and Hikaru agreed to a draw so uh
tomorrow is a rest today and they will
have all the time to prepare and the
rest for uh going into round seven fully
refreshed it's hard to say if they will
remain in the lead as most of the games
are still being played this was one of
the first games to finish so uh we'll
see what happens definitely going to
cover at least one more game uh from
this round but as there's a rest day
probably I will cover at least three
games from uh this round so use hashtag
suggestion and do suggest your favorites
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and like I said even though
we avoided the main line with C3 uh if
you want to check out that game I still
haven't made a video on it but you're
welcome to you know find some other
sources uh but I will maybe maybe I even
show this game on a rest day I'll see
I'll probably show it after the
tournament though uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank John gear Law Office LLC
Mario Milano the brers on Spotify Steven
mccan and chess beats league for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day